you ever feel - there was a certain
point in my life like I don't think I
hated being Korean but it was more along
the lines of I didn't really identify
myself as a Korean until I started to
get older oh and I started realizing
there were certain attributes just I
mean number when I was born in Korea my
parents are they don't speak any English
and I think that I don't think I was
ashamed of my culture but I didn't
identify with it very well and I and you
know I just grew up in a very diverse
area so it was and I didn't know too
many Korean people outside of my church
and I wasn't that close to a lot of the
church members except for a few people
so I don't think I kind of realized like
how important my culture was to Who I am
and my upbringing and the way that I
think until I started getting older and
I started hanging around other Korean
people I'm like oh we actually have a
lot of like like-minded things and it's
because it's from a cultural aspect like
for example I thought I would never be
with a Korean girl oh and now you know
being with Muriel yeah I realized how
important it was for me to be with
somebody who understands Korean culture
oh yeah yeah that makes sense the way I
view the world how I view like like like
like familial like piety and stuff like
that how I see family friend dynamic
friend dynamic it's all very creating
etiquette yeah
table conversation yeah all that stuff
yeah and in a lot of Asians can relate
to each other because it's similar
yeah it's rooted our philosophy is
rooted in Confucianism and even though
we might grow up Christian there's still
a lot of Buddhism Confucianism and that
kind of stuff just in the subtleness of
the culture that we all kind of tie us
regardless if you're Filipino or
whatever it all that's why we have that
mutual Asian understanding with a few
like differences but majority yeah you
know that we get along we get it
I wonder if sometimes I wanted to not to
say that I took the easy route in terms
of a relationship just you know dating
somebody who's Korean yeah because a lot
of the stuff was self-explanatory
because she already grew up in it so I
didn't have to explain it if I just if
it was that the easier route for me than
being with somebody who was not within
my culture I don't know because
you know like being in a serious
relationship with jazz even though we
didn't work out I feel that in some ways
that was easier even though it wasn't
the same culture you know but then again
I've never been with a Japanese girl
I've been with other Asian girls and so
that's not the same culture so it's just
it's just kind of similar because it's
Asian yeah there's this weird thing like
even when I when I look at Mariel and
then we have conversations and then I'll
say something in Korean right there was
there's like a weird comfort to it I
don't know what it is but it makes you a
lot more connected to her I can see that
you know yeah because even with my
Japanese friends right like I have my
super American eyes like their
grandparents can't even speak Japanese
yeah and then I have my like straight
from Japan friends and even Hawke like
Hawke is British Japanese he's floating
Japanese right yeah but there is a
certain thing that tie us all even like
you know like Ryan like like he's pretty
much white oh I forget he's Japanese
yeah yeah but the but the way he his
mannerisms are the way he thinks or
handles stuff a little bit I'm like this
that's pretty Japanese yeah and it's
weird it's it's it's weird because it's
like how does that piece of you continue
on yeah I always wondered that too yeah
like um like my mom always says to a my
dad he goes you know no matter how much
you try to deny you're who you are where
you came from it'll always seep out of
you yeah it you you think you're better
than where you're from but you're not
you know like you are you are there's
something in your blood is what they say
yeah you know yeah for me I feel like
I'm um I'm a mix of everything but it's
I never felt ashamed or to me was the
opposite from you it was like everyone
just called me Japanese or they called
me Chinese or Asian so that's what I
thought I was you know until I went to
Japan the older I got the more I
realized I'm an American yeah because I
didn't know what American was you know
when you're a kid you grow up and you
think American and you go white people
yeah that's just kind of in your head
from school and and just all this stuff
right
and you know you are but you what you
really are is your race yeah in America
it's like you know you know you're
you're you're a American but you're like
Asian first yeah right that's what you
think and then when I traveled and I'm
like I look like or they kind of look
like me but this is not my country and
we do not think the same yeah and that's
when I was like oh you know what
American is a state of mind in life and
it's a different thing from how it's
like it's it's to me it's it's more
about how you go by thinking and doing
life yeah versus like tradition or
whatever I don't know yeah I mean I
might have done a video on this back in
the day but I was talking about how
people had this weird perception of what
an American is specifically our parents
right and it's weird to us because we've
kind of evolved from whatever trials and
tribulations they went trying to be an
American right Mariel tells me the story
of her mom making sure that she would
eat McDonald's so she would be more
accepted as an American right hey make
sure that you eat hamburgers make sure
that you eat french fries because if not
these American people won't accept you
and you won't be considered American
that could have been true in her parents
generation yeah and um you know there's
a lot of like for example like Japanese
people yeah who were born here a few
generations and their parents were
scared for their kids so they don't
speak Japanese I don't even try that
[ __ ] so just only know English and so
they don't know anything about Japanese
culture they can't speak to language
because it was just it was taught it
wasn't taught to them yeah for a very
specific reason and I think from those
type of experiences a lot of people now
have this weird perception of what it is
to truly be an American
is it to assimilate into this white
culture or or now for for me like
definitively what being American is is
taking part of your culture and living
in this country and kind of you know
building your dream yeah I think for me
it's really about the whole foundation
and the philosophy of this call this
nation green you know it's about the
pursuit of freedom and what freedom
means